one by paul bremer who was a
presidential envoy to Iraq under former
president george w bush and also served
as US ambassador to the Netherlands Phil
Mattingly joining me as well the
Bloomberg White House correspondent who
has been on top of this unfolding story
and Phil let me start with you on these
troops a handful of troops that the
president is going to send that's right
Betty what the President did last night
is informed Congress that he has sent
275 troops to Iraq now these troops
Betty are being sent almost entirely for
protection reasons with the US Embassy
inside Baghdad however the president
also met last night with his top
national security team officials to
start weighing options here's what we
know is certainly on the table obviously
air strikes is something the
administration has opened the door to we
know drone operations are also something
they're looking at another issue emerged
last night and that's the possibility of
a limited number of special operators
also entering the country now Betty a
key point here that we've been told us
officials saying those operators
wouldn't be used for combat reasons but
they are essential if any type of air
strike or drone operation is to occur US
forces will need to be on the ground
purely for targeting and Intel purposes
Betty so lots of action but no concrete
moves yet an ambassador Paul you say
that that we need boots on the ground
yes basically along the lines that were
just described you know the is is
although it's been moving very fast the
last week really has some weaknesses
they're not very many of them they
number in the thousands they're lightly
armed and they are unpopular in effect
you can't go around executing prisoners
of war and be popular very long so we
have I think two military objectives we
need to stop the southward movement of
the is is and that will inquire require
airstrikes on their lines of
communication and eventually secondly
help the Iraqis retake the cities which
will require drone attacks you can't do
either of those effectively without good
intelligence and so we will have to have
intelligence collectors Special Forces
of some kind
forward fire control people on the
ground and I think we should therefore
insist when we do that that we get a
status of forces agreement for those
servicemen as we have all over the world
what kind of an operation what size of
my operation are we talking about I
don't that I would leave to the military
planners I think the important thing
here is now to get moving time as a
wasting president made his speech about
the interests that we have there on
friday it's now tuesday morning we need
to get going phil is there there is no
appetite is there we pulled out a few
years ago there's no appetite for among
Americans to go back into Iraq well
certainly if you look at public polling
no there's no appetite really for
Americans to have troops pretty much
anywhere right now if you look at it
look I think this is an issue of the
Obama administration is having a very
difficult time with Betty they've cited
pulling out of Iraq is one of their
primary foreign policy achievements for
the better part of the last two and a
half years this is an administration
that ran their first presidential
campaign on getting out of Iraq the fact
that they're faced with an incredibly
complex and as the ambassador said very
fast-moving issue right now is really
thrown them a bit for a loop I think
they've got a lot of options on the
table but how quickly they move on those
I think in part they're staring at the
situation saying I can't believe we are
dealing with a rock this many years
later ambassador you say that that is is
is is vulnerable that they're not that
well organized but are they well funded
well I didn't say they were not well
organized they are well organized they
just aren't that many of them and they
have vulnerabilities particularly in
their lines of communication leading
back to Syria they seem to have pinched
quite a lot of money from the banks in
Mosul so they seem to be well funded
look the president correctly identified
our major interest here on Friday when
he said that it is not in our interest
that this terrorist group should gain a
foothold in the heart of the Middle East
this is not Afghanistan behind the
mountain somewhere this is right in the
heart of historic Arab Middle East with
a lot of money
and the idea of the is is getting
control of Iraq should be a major
problem for America and I think that's
the interest we got to focus on right
now but explains me a little bit more
about how they're funded ambassador well
they've been funded because they've been
able to take over a lot of the eastern
part of Syria in the war against Assad
they are also getting funds from some
elements of the Gulf states as they as
al-qaida always did this is basically an
al-qaeda type organization although
they're even so extreme that al-qaeda
has you know declared they're not part
of us they basically are an al-qaeda
operation and they're funded more or
less as al Qaeda's been funded Phil is
there any any any possibility on the
financial side to weaken this group
Betty I think the difficulty that you
know look the US Treasury has been very
effective on the sanctions regime
anti-terror sanctions regime really
going back to the bush administration
the issue they're facing right now is
this group is largely kind of raiding
banks this seems very simplistic but
they're pulling millions of dollars out
of banks with each town they move
through so it's not an international
finance regime that they can disrupt so
that kind of limits if not eliminates
entirely what the US can do on that
front all right Phil thank you so much
Phil Mattingly our White House
correspondent also to ambassador Paul
Bremer the former presidential envoy to
Iraq